when you did Iron Man you said that was
more like a I I don't want to misquote
you but it was like kind of like a high
school kind of thing or an amateur
production because they wrote it as they
went along this was so amazing you know
I don't know 200 million dollars
whatever the thing cost do you think
they would have a script right you know
you would think yes but uh no who
directed that one was that fact
so here so here we are coming to work
and like you know you said you know I
like to be prepared I like to know my
lines and you know otherwise I'm super
nervous you know right so uh we would
often come to work and there would be no
script for that scene today and we would
muster in my trailer with Favreau and
Robert Downey and the suits man the guy
from Marvel right and we would sit in
there and I would say uh okay Robert you
play me and I'll play your guy so we
changed Parts favro would be calling
writer friends of his season here's the
scene now you got any ideas meanwhile
the cruise and they're tapping their
foot ready to go to work how can this be
and I was just I was you know such
stress until I made a little adjustment
in my soul or whatever saying Jeff will
you please relax you are making a 200
million dollar student film yeah
the 200 million dollar film think of it
as a student film and who you get to
play with and favro and Downy was okay
with this process well I don't know
about okay he he surfed the big you wave
just so beautifully he's amazing he's a
master actor he's a master improv
improviser as is favro right so when we
made that little we just championed had
fun and great stuff bubbled up out of it
and favro what was so great about him he
was able as the Director you can imagine
the uh the pressure and you know sure
but he was able to keep this thing
cooking with the suits in the room with
this the Marvel Guy saying I don't think
um you know uh Iron Monger would say
that you know right was able to not just
go ah get out of you and blow it he was
just you know surfing the whole thing so
beautifully but why wouldn't they do
that process ahead of time and and sit
there and have something on them exactly
well something was on the page but it
was the wrong something when you you
signed up did they show you a script uh
well they showed us the script we worked
for two weeks the three of us going over
the whole thing uh coming up with some
exciting stuff and changes and then the
day before the shooting they said no
this is no good and they threw it all
out do you ever say to yourself I should
have gotten a writing credit on this
movie no no no you don't care that's
just part of my you know that's part of
the acting thing it's such a Mass Appeal
movie everyone sees it is that a little
more exciting in a way because it really
does come down to how many people see
the movie right I mean for me that's the
best one of all of those kind of movies
the superhero movies that one just
shines and it's Downy man and federal
those guys just pretty pretty remarkable
foreign